un autre panel ce soir véronique prince
christian duffau aux folles journées et
madeleine blé morin pas se joindre à
nous un peu plus tard dans cours d'un
conventionnel bonsoir à vous soit mais
comment sont justement par la pandémie
se un an tout le monde se rappelle l'an
dernier j'étais où je faisais quoi pique
dont une dans quel tunnel on a commencé
à embarquer puis me semble que c'est
resté sont tellement tellement longtemps
j'ai le temps des bilans pour le
gouvernement c'est ce que vous avez fait
d'ailleurs véronique avec françois
legault avec votre entrevue on ne
diffuse et en tout quelques extraits il
dépend des décisions très difficiles en
cours de route monsieur leubou entre
autres changer la ministre la santé ce
qui paraît un petit extrait de
l'entrevue que vous avez vous avez
réalisé avec lui moi je vous dirais que
daniel mais kahn était la meilleure
personne
après gaétan barrette pour apaiser les
réseaux et puis re motiver les réseaux
je pense que christian une approche un
peu plus car ce qui est nécessaire
actuellement parce que il ya un travail
à faire sur l'imputabilité donc erronée
qu'il cherchait des gens avec la poignée
finalement plus de points que madame
mais cannes oui et pas juste dans son
ministre christian dubé mais également
les hauts fonctionnaires de mick savoie
qui a été recruté on sait aussi que
l'uci au pas terni c'est elle qui
surveille les listes d'attentes des
chirurgies elle aussi les quand même
réputée pour sa main de fer parce que
françois legault avait besoin de
quelqu'un le plus de risques avec plus
de rigidité pour attaquer la pandémie il
ne va pas jusqu'à saluer la proche mort
est il tellement critiqué quand il était
dans l'opposition
non dans l'entrevue c'est comme si en
quelque part ils reconnaissent et quand
même que ça prenait une certaine fermeté
peut-être pas sortir le fouet comme get
en baroeul faisais mes adieux du moins
parfois sortir le bâton pour que les
gestionnaires soit davantage imputable
et responsable et daniel mais cannes
peut-être qu'avant la pandémie c'était
parfait sa douceur pouvoir la transition
à prague et à barrett
mais elle n'incarne est pas la rigidité
que françois legault avait besoin pour
faire face à cette crise
ouais paul il faut dire qu'ils avaient
vraiment tous tellement choses à
reprendre en main dans la santé
l'immortalité
c'est lié à ce ministère la les sièges
serbie
ce qui s'est passé avec les hôpitaux les
transferts de patients le personnel qui
se promenait partout mais
essentiellement le manque d'imputabilité
oui puis là la difficulté à y voir clair
à comprendre ce qui se passe dans le
réseau françois legault en interview
avec avec moi avec la pince il nous
racontait aussi que dans la plupart de
ces questions dans la cellule de crise
était pour yvan gendron lancé sous
ministre de la santé puis quand il
commence à y avoir plein d'éclosion dans
les chu c'est l'idée il sortait la liste
des 6 h et celle d où ça allait mal puis
dire c'est qui le patron ce qui la
patronne à cet endroit là ce qui est bon
ce qui est bon whisky mauvais puis l'on
n'est pas capable de répondre à ça puis
le tendance anglais au logo s'intéresser
beaucoup aux détails et ils s'évitent
impatiente et de l'incapacité divan
gendron et danielle mccann de répondre à
ces questions cela dit au delà de la
personnalité de ces deux individus et
aussi la question de la structure du
réseau lui même sont hyper
centralisation et et ça c'est quelque
chose même si on change les têtes qu'on
règle le repos mais bon les personnes
qui veulent défaire la réforme barrette
la proposition monsieur le goût est plus
modeste de restaurer l'imputabilité de
l'augmenter on a déjà vu que c'est plus
compliqué dans le détail avec daniel
paris responsable la campagne de
vaccination qui est encore en poste
malgré ce pont d'arve qui sauvent sont
passés au sus de chaudière appalaches
donc s avez-vous l'impression
effectivement le convoi les effets de
tout ça de tous ces décisions difficiles
mais ces changements de garde changement
à la tête du ministère de la santé
finalement c'est une bonne chose
bah je trouve qui est trop tôt pour
faire un bilan
parce qu'on est enlisée en fait dans la
pandémie c'est un rapport d'étape sa fin
a fait mal qu'après un an on se pose de
questions l'habitabilité c'est le maître
mot
je contacte monsieur legault appareils
se préoccuper beaucoup par ça mais il
faut être réaliste il ya un problème
spécifiquement québécois la société
québécoise à gauche le monstre
bureaucratique où tout a pu depuis à
imputabilité en pratique
est impossible et moi ce que je note
dans les secondes qui est bien c'est que
monsieur legault ne semble pas vouloir
admettre qu'un problème québécois là
dedans c'est que le bila québec
objectivement et honteux par rapport au
reste du canada se démarque nettement
empire et et célia certains spécificité
identitaire c'est pour ça qu'il est
difficile de confronter sa yo le bilan
comme tel de l'administration legault de
monsieur legault lui-même quand on peut
critiquer ou défendre une chose il ya
aussi notre système public de santé et
de services sociaux qui était
dysfonctionnel à mon avis c'est un poème
scénique puis aussi la société
québécoise
comment ça se fait que nous les
québécois beaucoup plus qu'ailleurs on a
tendance avec les vieux si je caricature
dans des dans des centres comme ça donc
c'est un gros problème et monsieur
legault veut pas aller sur ce sur ce
terrain n'oserait mais j'ai jamais vu
admettre c'est vrai qu'au québec ça
moyen d'aller à certains égards
qu'ailleurs jamais dit ça mais c'est
vrai effectivement véronique il le fait
d'ailleurs dans votre entrevue il le
fait à chacune de ces entrevues il se
compare avec des pires ou des gens qui
ont eu pratiquement autant en difficulté
que le québec
il repose comparer avec les meilleurs
non effectivement il va se comparer
aussi beaucoup avec ceux qui ont pris le
même genre de décision que lui la
saskatchewan l'alberta la
colombie-britannique notamment
concernant l' enquête publique
on sait que l'ontario temps se compare à
tous les jours là avec l'ontario mais
pour ce qui est des enquêtes publiques
il faut pas faire la comparaison avec
cette province là parce que l'ontario a
choisi l enquête publique même si on n'a
pas nécessairement vu encore cette
portion public là alors il dit qu'il
n'est pas borné au contraire ils
écoutent cnn toute la nuit chez qu'il
l'a répété plusieurs fois en entrevue
justement pour voir ce qui se fait
ailleurs pour se comparer à d'autres et
à d'autres dirigeants et le conforter
finalement dans ses décisions parce que
il sait qu'il ne s'appuie pas
complètement sur la santé publique il le
dit en entrevue il ya le côté
faisabilité qui vient mots toujours avec
classe la santé publique parfois des
recommandations sur tout simplement pas
faisable
parlons justement de santé publique
monsieur harouna qui l'incarnent c'est
lui qui est à la tête de tout ça c'est
lui donc il doit conseiller le
gouvernement en a qui étaient présentes
et c'est une révélation il ya un an paul
c'est devenu
il y avait des mêmes de lui les gens se
l'arrachent et pratiquement il est
tellement perdu de son lustre depuis
quelle est son influence encore
aujourd'hui quel rôle joue aujourd'hui à
votre avis mais son influence est encore
grande
il faut comprendre que horacio arruda
c'est le directeur national de la santé
publique mais il est directeur dans
chaque région
donc monsieur arruda quand il parle
monsieur legault avant il a consulté les
collègues de chaque région donc qui les
représentent eux aussi ce qui augmente
son influence mais on le vu le premier
ministre hall dernier mot au début au
milieu de la crise il disait toujours je
ne fais que suivre la santé publique
mais finalement on réalise qui souvent
il a été plus loin
peut-être entre autres par une question
de tempérament de tolérance face aux
risques monsieur legault c'est pas
quelqu'un très très patient n'est
capable de décider rapidement avec une
qualité comme un défaut mais taille
dernière chose que je dirais sur horacio
arruda son influence t elle pas face au
gouvernement
mais sa légitimité quand il parle par
rapport au public
assurément elle diminué entre autres
parce qu'on a appris même si les pôles
seul que quand la co vite quand les
coptes commencé à éclater un peu partout
sur la terre ben lui faisait pas partie
des inquiète ça lui a pris quand même
beaucoup de temps avant de prévenir un
monsieur lebon on comprend qu'un premier
ministre c'est pas à lui d'être au
courant des tendances épidémiologiques
mais on aurait pu croire que monsieur
arruda aurait été impliqué la question
là dessus parce que monsieur ndao si une
de ses particularités
c'est sa difficulté parfois communiquer
simplement le message à un tel point
qu'on a engagé quelqu'un qui est rendu
pratiquement un permanent le maintenant
assez bête pour quelques mois mais on a
longé le contrat vous en pensez-quoi
aujourd'hui à la suite de tous les
épisodes qu'on a connu entre autre celui
qui a marqué tout le monde c'est un non
non non limaces pas bon vous savez pas
utilisés sont finalement des masses la
portée de tout le monde puis
pratiquement importés en deux lots
parce qu'il est tellement monté haut au
début que ça peut juste descendre en
fait il faisait très sympathique très
rassurant il ya été surexposés comme
beaucoup de ses personnages
c'est sûr que beaucoup de crédibilité
surtout que un des éléments je trouve
sain de ce qu'on apprend ces temps ci
c'est que monsieur legault assume les
décisions qui ont été les siennes dans
beaucoup de cas y est allé plus loin que
les recommandations de la santé publique
était plus strict moi personnellement ça
n'engage que moi
voici une critique que je fais à la
gestion de monsieur legault chose qui
était trop stricte il sous-estimé
l'importance des choses supposément non
importante mais qui peuvent l'être
beaucoup comme la culture la joie de
vivre le plaisir les restaurants tout ça
pour le moral des québécois a été
important et monsieur legault fait son
choix il assume c'est ça qui est bien
mais ce n'est pas une recommandation de
la santé publique là dessus mais pour
terminer sur votre thème je pense que
monsieur roux doit y est encore là celle
des comme un totem quelques pauvres et
d'ici là mais c'est clair que vraiment
plus la crédibilité qu'il y avait avant
le sent bon sur le délestage maintenant
véronique ça vous a même fait sursauter
comme journaliste quand il vous a dit
monsieur le goût que le délestage là au
québec ça n'a fait aucun mort et c'est
beaucoup beaucoup avancé évidemment ici
il suit à son entourage ainsi est-ce
qu'on lui rapporte aussi et vous vous
trouvez qu'ils prennent un risque et ce
parce que c'est tellement dur à vérifier
c'est tellement dur à quantifier il peut
y avoir toutes sortes de variables alors
est-ce qu'on peut s'avancer jusqu'à dire
qu'il ya eu aucun mort au québec due aux
délestages
alors qu'au moment où on se parle on a
quand même presque cent quarante cinq
mille personnes qui attendent sur la
liste là et donc françois legault se
fissure sa sous-ministre lucie opa
techniques surveillent tout ça est
apparemment qui lui a téléphoné
la fin de semaine dernière mais l'autre
d'avant parce que ça l'inquiétait
beaucoup le dossier de la jeune rosine
chouinard chauveau et mère de 28 ans a
fait les manchettes
elle est décédée alors qu'elle se
trouvait sont des attentes alors il a
multiplié les appels et une vérification
il dit je vous l'assuré je les vérifier
moi-même sa liste d'attentes à elle sur
lequel laquelle elle se trouvait il y en
avait pas de délestage mais c'est clair
qu'il reconnaît qu'il ya des québécois
qui va en voir à tout le moins une santé
très hypothéquer mais quand c'est une
question de vie ou de mort il assure que
l'opération est toujours pratique pas ce
qu'on peut dire bon il n'y a pas une
mort due aux usa mais pas l'on peut
quand même dire il ya des retards qui
font en sorte qu'ils aient des
agnostiques qui se font pas il ya des
traitements qui vont être en retard il
ya des gens qui vont voir leur état
s'aggrave et parfois de telle sorte
qu'on ne raccourcit leur espérance de
vie
mais oui parce que de savoir s'il ya eu
des morts ou non comme véronique le bien
explicite absolument invérifiable ce qui
est certain c'est qu'il ya des gens qui
en souffrent en ce moment et qui vont en
souffrir
c'est pour ça que les propos de monsieur
leubou m'ont un peu étonné parce que je
sais que autant lui que son ministre
christian dubé sont au courant que le
délestage c'est un problème et qui
veulent s'y attaquer mais bon la
meilleure façon de régler le délestage
c'est de gagner plus rapidement possible
le combat contre la pandémie
mais bon le délestage aussi ça la liste
d'attentes telles existait avant la
coved ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'elle est
si grande en ce moment et on en voyait
déjà les conséquences c'est pas trop
trop difficiles à comprendre si vous
regardez votre votre opération
ou si vous regardez le moment vous allez
faire une vérification avec votre
médecin mais ça peut avoir des
conséquences fâcheuses sur votre santé
il ya même des gens qui sont apparus ce
moral des québécois il ya des gens qui
ont peur de se rendre à l'hôpital ils
ont peur d'aller voir leur médecin parce
qu'ils ont peur d'attraper la copie de
l'hôpital aussi bah oui moi même c'est
anecdotique mais j'ai retardé en fait
d'aller chez le dentiste pour un
nettoyage que jeter comme un peu
insécure pour pour rien quelque part ça
me tandis que monsieur legault focalise
sur le fait que peu ils marcheront pas
que une mort c'est terrible parce que
c'est clair que le délestage en si tous
je veux dire il ya tant de gens qui sont
en train de tomber malade parce qu'ils
vont plus aux médecins
le médecin ils font plus d'exercice donc
le communisme de suspension du système
sanitaire
donc je trouve qui est vraiment trop tôt
pour faire un bilan réel puis jovialiste
surtout ceux ci dessus c'est une étape
puis le délestage je trouve que c'est
une stress c'est une tragi tue de plus
en plus je comprends monsieur legault
mais vous j'avoue j'ai trouvé un petit
peu trop comment dire mes parents du
maire parce que ça vous préoccupe
beaucoup moral des troupes le moral de
tout le monde la société
on a fait un sondage réseau canadien
sondage ipsos est ce qu'on voit c'est
que les gens effectivement ben non c'est
les canadiens sont pessimistes ils sont
résignés
le trois quarts pensent qu' il va avoir
encore déconfinement répétition cours de
la prochaine année
mais ce qui est marquant c'est que 76%
crise un appuierait un nouveau
confinement pour ralentir la propagation
donc les gens l'adhésion la règle elle
est encore très présent oui c'est vrai
vous le slip ça frottait beaucoup de
monde dispose de résiliation moi je
trouve la situation
bon on peut pas s'étonner que les gens
soient au chaud des prix mais surtout
que ça y est le sondage a quand même été
feuilles deux semaines à un moment où on
avait beaucoup de doutes
en fait sur la disponibilité des vaccins
de cette bonne nouvelle cette semaine
aussi je trouve que si j'avais à définir
la france on vit actuellement c'est
l'enlisement
c'est que c'est comme si une idéologie
sans terre que pour une fois que pris le
contrôle il ya d'autres discours tu peux
critiquer aussi mais il ya toujours
l'idéologie center qui a impose sa loi
et vous avez remarqué que l'on parle
plus tellement du virus on parle du
variant maintenant maintenant c'est la
terreur du variant on n'avait même pas
50 et vaccins arriverait qu'on s'en
sortir l on n'avait pas ça que les
vaccins sont arrivés mais c'est pas
exactement ce qu'on veut c'est pas
totalement efficace viol et dont je
comprends les gens d'être déprimée parce
qu'on se dit on veut s'en sortir un jour
quelque part je sais que c'est pas peu
fier de moi je trouve que l'idéologie
sanitaire au delà on n'est pas dans la
science une idéologie sanitaire que plus
de pouvoir quelques pas ouais mais qui
êtes chez vous aussi puisque vous étiez
en europe si vous rendez vous shield ans
exactement le contact vous disais ça
parce que je mange que je croise il
depuis un an on a tous été changé la
part de pénétrer tout ce qu'on en est
parce que ça fait un an qu'on ne parle
que de ça comment voulez vous ne pas
être changées bon mais là on arrive
peut-être à la fameuse
bout du tunnel on n'arrête pas d'en
parler avec la vaccination mais aulas
voit concrètement le ca commence à
prendre son envol
et c'est là je vais rajouter un joueur à
notre équipe de panélistes madeleine blé
maurey qui va se joindre à nous mais on
n'est que je vais vous demander de céder
votre place merci beaucoup de vos
réelles avec vous ce soir c'est vraiment
intéressant nous entendre sur l'entrevue
que vous avez réalisé avec monsieur
legault alors je dis bonjour à mad men
dont on parle de sondages madeleine on
vous voyez que ça le deal sa
construction de creux de vague parce que
les vaccins ça rentrait pas il y avait
des retards mais le sait contraire si on
faisait un sondage aujourd'hui peut-être
qu'on aurait d'autres types de résultats
les gens on le sentait aujourd'hui sont
un petit peu plus soulagé c'est vraiment
les boks pop qu'on a fait là dans les
lieux aujourd'hui il y avait de la
vaccination santé une espèce de retour
là la vraie vie normale hirel avec un
petit peu plus de lumière dans les yeux
il ya comme un pacte avec une
corrélation et les rumeurs d'élection
qu'on commence entente faites vous un
lien a évidemment parce que l'ingrédient
central du prochain scrutin c'est
comment va se dérouler la campagne de
vaccination si ça va bien pour le
gouvernement trudeau
il va être davantage tenté de se rendre
peut-être même lui même à rideau hall
pour déclencher des élections
mais là c'est un gros client parce que
vous l'avez dit deux semaines lorsqu'on
a réalisé ce reportage là on sentait
dollar la morosité de la résignation
deux semaines plus tard ça change
donc on est dans des temps qui sont très
très changeant et ça j'en suis certaine
que les libéraux en sont pleinement
conscients aussi y aurait un risque de
déclencher des élections et finalement
voir que les retards dans les
approvisionnements d'un maxi de vaccins
se produise à nouveau
donc on n'est pas à l'abri de nouveaux
soubresauts dans cette campagne de
vaccination là donc j'ai l'impression
que les prochaines semaines vont être
fondamental dans justement ces calculs
là que devrait faire le gouvernement
du côté de l'opposition je descends au
moins moi cette ferveur électorale là il
ya même le npd qui disait il ya quelques
jours on se repose les responsables du
déclenchement des élections
ça ressemblait presque à un chèque en
blanc l'a enlevée vers le parti libéral
de dire bon on n'en veut pas d'élection
donc ne soyez pas très très très
stressée avec nous
on va pas provoquer d'élections mais pas
c'est tellement un énorme pari de dire
bah on pourrait peut-être le temps tu es
notre couple à aller en élections parce
qu on a l'exemple des provinces il ya
des endroits où effectivement les
gouvernements province ont gagné leur
pari mais on a vu ce qui s'est passé à
terre-neuve
c'était une catastrophe écoutez il a
fallu qu'on repousse tout appuyons c'est
pour vous est tellement de questions sur
bon on la vit comment cette élection on
arrête la machine c'est parce que le
gouvernement libéral veut voir nature
interne va vraiment changer la
perception parce que dans les derniers
mois on n'arrêtait pas de répéter les
exemples la colombie-britannique du
nombre de jouets pour un gouvernement
minoritaire avec une majorité graves
durant la crise et grâce à la crise et
terre-neuve
quand l'élection a été déclenchée ça
allait très bien sur le plan
épidémiologique la terre neuve puis ça a
complètement basculé une semaine avant
le scrutin et puis on a mis fin au vote
en personne trois jours avant cette
catastrophe et terre-neuve pourtant et
autres provinces à ces petites alors
imaginez à l'échelle du canada à quel
point ce genre de dérapage pourrait se
produire avec très proches très peu
d'avertissements
cela dit quand on évoque un scénario
d'élections printanières habituellement
on pense quelques jours quelques
semaines après le budget qui
habituellement fédéral est déposée début
mars mais n'ont pas vraiment faim
printemps le plus tôt mais voir juin est
bon il ya deux choses à vérifier
premièrement le thermomètre la fièvre
électorale et pas mal égal au résultat
des partis dans les sondages et on sent
que l'intérêt est plus du côté des
libéraux
l'autre chose à surveiller vous l'avez
dit c'est la campagne de vaccination si
la campagne de vaccination n'avance pas
bien une élection ne serait probablement
pas souhaitable pour des raisons
sanitaires ni souhaitable pour les
libéraux selon leurs intérêts partisans
parce que c'est la vaccination va mal
les gens sont frustrés sont frustrés ils
voteront propos justin trudeau
mais je pense que c'est difficile
vraiment de mesurer l'humeur des
canadiens ce moment j'attendrai
peut-être plus les résultats du sondage
dans six semaines environ
question moi j'veux pas sûr que les
analogies avec les provinces soutiennent
parce qu'une élection canadien du
fédéral sur une ampleur beaucoup plus
importante
c'est très risqué en fait pour les
libéraux se lancer là dedans parce
qu'ils peuvent se récuser facilement
d'être opportuniste opinion publique
peut changer beaucoup
c'est pas comme au québec un ralliement
très remarquable massif jusqu'à présent
autour du gouvernement legault bon
ottawa les libéraux change bien placé
jusqu'à un certain point il ya quand
même des critiques à l'égard de chute
est rude aux temps passés ce bien parce
que les accusations d'un opportunisme
une élection fédérale ce n'est pas comme
à terre-neuve une élection fédérale
actuellement parce que ça ferait pas
irresponsable parce que c est ce que
demandaient les canadiens se mettra pas
en vouloir aux libéraux moi je fais bien
attention à leur casse ouais m'écouter
merci beaucoup pour ce panel merci
madame de votre visite
merci beaucoup puis à bientôt en voir un
merci pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]